now i'm going to take you to mid-july
2013 the tokyo press tour for lone
ranger can you please tell the jury
about that particular trip and the
events relating to mr depp
uh sure he was promoting a lone ranger
and
i had just met his kids
at the premiere in los angeles shortly
before this tour started
they
found out about me um
amber i'm gonna just ask you not to go
through that just just take us to tokyo
please okay so i believe we went from
that stop to tokyo
uh with the kids
and
he had had
difficulty with drinking in front of
them he was trying to hide it and
yet he was dealing with some stress some
stress around his career i didn't have a
lot of details but
he was drinking um
at the restaurant
and the kids were kind of
you know
noticing but not
not really sure what to make of it
objection calls for speculation and
hearsay
she was she didn't say what they said
sustain us to the last part of the
answer okay please please continue but
don't say what they said okay the kid
said um anyway i
johnny became um
upset with me for
judging him
he was
he was
you know
i couldn't it was like i couldn't win if
i didn't do anything
if i didn't say anything to him about
the drinking if i didn't acknowledge it
it got worse if i did acknowledge it it
was my fault and i was nagging
and i get it you know
i wouldn't like to be told what to do
either so but it made him really angry
and the kids were in in the
on this press tour and i was just
concerned about them i was concerned
about them hearing us
tony screamed at me
in the hotel room and all i could think
where the kids were in an adjoining room
what if they could hear us you know i i
had just met them and i didn't want them
to think
poorly of me
and
hate me not knowing what was going on
you know in our behind closed doors
i i i just um
i remember and
it was name calling and he eventually
passed out do you recall what names he
called you do you recall what he said
uh i heard at this time nagging
nagging all the time called me
uh he even said that he made a mistake
uh with me and
then he didn't want to that when we
touched back down
he'd get rid of me and i'd go back to
he said some
disgusting things to me i don't
know if i need to repeat it